this podcast is brought to you by on it
go to honor.com and look at the great
selection of supplements if you find
something you like
pressing code joey and get 10 off
delivered right to your house
greetings from podcastville it's monday
memorial day the joint is brought to you
by
blue chew listen
summer's here and it's time to go shoot
that [__] rocket between your legs up
somebody's [__] muffler you
understand me blue chew is tremendous
you could take it any time
day or night if you have erectile
dysfunction you know like if your dick
still works but you want some extra
[__] confidence blue chew is the
answer i like blue chew it comes in a
little personalized package you open up
you can put it in your [__] pocket
and when you're ready a sling dick you
open it pop the pill in your mouth give
yourself 40 minutes and it's all over
from the shout
the process is simple you sign up at
bluetooth.com
and talk to one of the licensed medical
providers once you're approved you'll
receive your prescription within days
it's all online
no doctor's office no pharmacy no
judgment it ships right to your door in
a discrete package
bluetooth tablets are made in the usa
and they're way cheaper than the
pharmacy you know how much [__] they
want to charge me for viagra without
insurance even with insurance because
the pharmacy won't take anymore
eighty dollars a pill
tell them to suck your dick and call you
shorty so if you can benefit from the
extra confidence when it's time to sling
dick and perform blue chew can help and
they got a special deal
for the joint family try blue chew for
free
when you use my promo code joey at check
out j-o-e-y
just pay five dollars for shipping
that's blueshoot.com
promo code joey to receive your first
month free
visit bluetooth.com
for more details and safety information
and i want to thank blue chew for
sponsoring the [__] joint the joint
is also brought to you by on it and it's
been around with me for [__] 10 years
whether it's some new mood whether it's
the shroom tech immune or shroom tech
sport or the new
black label [__]
alpha brain that's it i'm sorry i had a
brain fart there
alpha brain the new black label is
[__] tremendous by the looks of me
stuttering it's time for me to [__]
uh take some more [__] alpha brain
but this whole situation did you see the
[__] anyway it doesn't [__] matter
go to honor.com they're having a
tremendous sale
on club bets and [__] mace and all
that stuff i can't get you a discount
but the sale will be enough but if
there's a supplement you want
press encode joey joint or church and
get 10 off your first order let's get
this [__] party started with a little
on it and a little [__] blue
chew you can't lose
welcome to uncle joey's joy
[Music]
my
what's happening you bad [__]
happy memorial day everybody i know you
should be barbecuing by now whatever but
hey some people like podcasts on
memorial day and you know me i gotta
[__] fill the void i'm not gonna keep
you here all [__] day or whatever
i know you got [__] to go to and so the
[__] do i but it was a great weekend all
in no
you know it rained in jersey [__]
friday
we opened up saturday with a little
[__] rain but hey for the most part
it was great
i'm headed to a [__] game tonight my
first baseball game and like uh
i don't know [__] three years yeah i
just got
i'm in the mood for a [__] game just
to sit and breathe and
you think you know people i don't know i
go to baseball games i love it
especially in the daytime if you know if
it's too [__] hot it's a nightmare i
mean when ralphie may first hit
when he first hit
he was spending [__] money like a
savage
and he asked me if i wanted to go to a
dodger game
they were playing the houston astros and
clemens was pitching
and i go ralphie whatever the [__] you
want you know ralphie
uh
didn't think about [__] we none of us do
you know we just
so he called the scalper and paid like
you know
two thousand dollars for the best ticket
in [__] uh
at the la dodger game now this is before
little edibles
like all these little edibles we have
now this is when we were going to a weed
shop next to dukes
that had
eggs like just beautiful cakes
like this these people make cakes so
everything was a [__] cake this big
to get you high you know
and the cakes were good i mean don't get
me wrong the the thc was great we didn't
know about
milligrams and all that [__] then
but you had to eat this whole big
[__] piece of cake you know like to
get high so
ralphie picks me up and he's like i just
got back from that [__] place i got
all types of weed
all types of edibles but he had
in those days guys they gave him a bag
this small for the weed he had probably
some joints in there and like maybe
three quarter ounces or an ounce of weed
whatever it was
but the other two bags were huge grocery
bags because of the size of these
[__] cakes and ralphie didn't know
what i wanted so he bought one of each
god bless this [__]
so we're sitting outside dodger stadium
in his [__] brand new car
living like doctors right just eating
that eating [__] cakes with no milk
just eating cakes eating cakes horrible
horrible and as we're walking in yeah we
got overwhelmed with the
with the [__]
get overwhelmed as soon as we walk out
of the [__] car guys
we walk out
and guys
it's a hundred [__] degrees
it is brutal it's like an august day it
is [__] brutal up
so we walk into the [__] stadium as
i'm walking in i'm already [__] high
like all this sugar and all this
frosting you know it was like three
pieces of cake i haven't eaten three
pieces of cake in 30 [__] years so i
was out of it
we walk in and yes they were the best
seats in the house there was only one
problem
the sun
was right above us and you could see
like when we got there we were sitting
by ourselves we're like ralph you got
great seats no nobody sits in that area
because they know you're gonna burn the
[__] debt
so we're sitting in that [__] area
i'm talking about the thc from the cake
is hitting me
the [__] sugars hitting me the
frosting is hitting me everything's
hitting me i got [__] cottonmouth
because you know how they show up every
water water beer whatever the [__]
and i'm sitting there [__] melting
under this [__] sun it was the most
uncomfortable
anything i've been in in years i mean i
couldn't believe i was uncomfortable
being high you know you were like yeah
you never get uncomfortable being high i
was [__] uncomfortable we looked at
each other like after two innings he was
covered in sweat he had sweat coming
from everywhere and he was a die-hard
ralph he got blessed his soul he was
like man i'm okay ralphie i look like a
ralphie not me
i'm about to [__] pass out when i got
home my wife had a rub
aloe
juice
[__] triple antibiotic on me i had
blisters for a [__] month
so sometimes the daytime game ain't that
[__] good you know what i'm saying
oh just a little ralphy story there i
was thinking about that when he [__]
did that and i was just uh
it was just a [__] up day
you know
i was having a great week this week and
we listen it's been great
thank god the chessbom and terry thank
god to my man ricky williams who came on
i know a lot of you people don't like to
zoom he's in l.a what do you want me to
do helicopter a minute listen it is what
the [__] it is guys at least i'm [__]
trying okay that's the most important
thing that we put effort into this
and we try and we write a little bit
before i come on here and come in on
here prepared i'm [__] trying
so
it was a great week i i did some good
things this week i didn't get on stage
last week but this week i got like four
[__] shows
which leads into friday night with joe
and said because i knew
if i spaced it out i'm not gonna be the
same i need to be loose the week of so i
need to be loose like the week of i
don't need to be listen right now i
guys i fell asleep i didn't i wrote but
i didn't uh
execute like i was going to but in the
in the meantime i knew that if i got on
stage twice a week it wasn't gonna be
enough like it wasn't gonna be enough
nothing was gonna be enough for me to
get back to top [__] form but
i figure if i get out tuesday wednesday
and thursday i'll be a lot looser for
friday i got i i got a half a set
written out you know
but uh i'm happy i'm happy because i
just want to get this over with to see
how i feel to see how i react to 6 000
people
so i could uh make a decision of what
i'm gonna do the rest of my [__] life
guys that's basically where i'm at but
this week was a little bit on the
[__] weird side for me man and it had
to do with that shooting in texas i
gotta be honest with you i don't really
get affected by news but i was thinking
about something
you know one of the worst drug weeks for
me was that i'll never ever forget
the week of the oklahoma bombing
that was i started snorting on monday
and i was just finishing up on tuesday i
woke up i went out i tried to get my
life back and all and there was a
bombing and i think i started snoring
that tuesday night
and i didn't stop till saturday i don't
know what triggered that for years i
couldn't figure out what the [__]
happened that week let me tell you how
much coke i did that week
i couldn't go out for a week after that
because i had burn marks
on my nose from the straw
i had cut the coke with like vitamin c
and now i was stuck with it so i had to
snort it
and it destroyed everything in me i mean
i was [__] ashamed
and for four days i just sat there guys
drinking [__] fat tires
and snorting coke looking at
them
take the rubble off these kids you know
it was i
and guys i was
it was 95 so i was what 32 i was still a
[__] savage with no remorse
it just tore into me like uh nothing
that week like it just really tore into
me and this week i was fine on [__]
tuesday
we did the podcast with ricky and later
on that day i hear about the shooting
you know what guys you try to
i really try to block the negative [__]
out of my mind
especially since the pandemic with the
information and everything
but there's some [__] that just gets
under your fingernails that you can't
avoid and this has been this thing you
know and
i saw a video of the parents outside
yelling for the cops to go in and
[Music]
i saw them tase a mom
and i know that they handcuffed another
mom and
the system failed this guys
and i don't want anybody to think like
most people attacked the gun issue and
yes there's no reason why an 18 year old
boy on the day of his birthday should be
able to go to a [__] gun store
and buy an ar-15 and guys you know me
you know i like violence i like shooting
i like burning people i like all that
[__] but i'm telling you right now
with all the faults i had growing up i
never had the fault
of getting a gun and going in front of
my friends and shooting them i never had
that fault and i was a dangerous person
obviously i went to jail they threw me
in jail for my actions
but that was never me hurting my friends
or wanting to hurt a child
that's never been me i've never been a
heavy
i'm just a [__] i got a bad tempo and
a bad attitude sometimes and i don't
think before i strike
but i never ever ever in all my life
with the situation i was in at 16
guys this kid got into a fight with his
[__] mother
about wi-fi or something you know and
he laughed and i did you know all the
reports about transgender and this
doesn't matter
you know why guys because at the age of
i was in worse shape
than that kid than the kid who shot
buffalo up then half these [__]
teenagers that are doing these horrific
acts
i was broken at 18 years old i killed
bugs
i kicked animals i did not care about
life life
[__] took a [__] on my head
and i never ever was that [__] up
that i wanted to get a gun and inflict
damage
to my friends this isn't a gun problem
guys
this is a [__] mental health problem
for you [__] who locked us in
for three [__] years
now you're getting to reap
what happened to these kids they've been
telling us for years 60 minutes had a
[__] show about it two times in the
last three months about what has
happened to children
since this [__] pandemic what the
[__] is going on
but for 19 cops to be outside and for
not one of those [__] cowboys to go
in there with their [__] hats and go
in there and then you guys saw the press
conference
abbott looks [__] stunned
you know his plan backfired
him that senator cruz i mean when you
look at them they're all a bunch of
[__] miserable bastards it doesn't
take a genius you don't need to be a phd
those people don't give a [__] about
anything
you know
for the first time in my life i'm a
little scared about this situation
this
you know i thought by today with the nra
convention in houston
and all those parents i mean my heart
goes out to those [__] parents i i i
can't
you know i got a daughter she's nine
years old mike's got children
i thought about
my teacher friends at [__] north
bergen high i thought about
you know my other teacher friends that
are at the grammar school in north
america i thought about all these
[__] things because you have to
you have to how does an american parent
right now feel mike's got two young kids
at home
if at one point
in the next two weeks
mike's girlfriend fiance is going to
come up to him and go what are we going
to do with our kids
i mean
do you have if you're a parent do you
have trust
in the school system
anymore i mean especially after reading
the articles that you're about to read
the next [__] four days
i don't know how i don't know how they
could regain trust
one of the things that keeps me
you know lets me go to sleep at night is
that there's two cops at my daughter's
school
so there's two cops at her school maybe
one cop at her school and one cop at the
other school and they're right across
the street from each other
so the only thing i see is that there's
a shootout here and there's a [__]
partner and he starts shooting the kids
in here but i don't want to think about
that as a parent i don't want to think
about that as my little girl
you know everybody and i've been saying
this since the [__] church
to keep your [__] eyes open
not look at your [__] phone it
doesn't matter who's texting you doesn't
matter what [__] brian karen told joe
rogan
when you're out there you gotta pay
[__] attention
to everything i am sick and tired of
saying this that life is not a [__]
bingo game
it's not a [__] bingo game it's
getting serious out there
everything i spoke about when i moved
here everything i spoke about the
pandemic is now coming to [__] light
right in front of our eyes
do you know a thousand flights got
cancelled this last weekend
[Music]
shortage of staff no planes
thousand [__] flights god
how is the american family gonna take a
[__] vacation
you ever think about that
mike can you avoid four tickets in a
thousand dollars to go to disneyland
you know this is the things i think of
can you afford four [__] tickets to
go to a yankee game
with your family on a book 25 a ticket
all your kid wants to see as a baseball
game i am [__]
depressed about the middle class in this
town
in this country they have
gotten rid of it
i'm not here to bring doom tea on monday
i'm here to bring you light and for you
guys to open your eyes
because it ain't going to get no [__]
better and all we have during these
times are ourselves
and our family and you got to protect
what the [__] you got
i am
lost about last week and you guys know
me i don't care about [__] anything
and every day i walk past second i don't
even want to look like all weekend i
didn't want to look at that [__]
computer i didn't want to know what the
[__] happened i don't give a [__]
anymore i just know that somewhere
the system [__] failed us somewhere
somewhere
these are our children
if we don't feel safe about sending our
children to school what you don't think
i'm gonna drive by that my daughter's
school twice a day from now on
you don't think that's the type of
person i am
at night when i go out if i ever go out
before i come home i drive by jimmy's
house i drive by my friend christina's
house because i know she's there alone
i'm one of those [__] jerk clothes
so you don't think now i got to drive by
the school two three times a [__] day
instead of going to lilly field and
walking i'm gonna walk by the school
from now on instead of making my calls
by little league field i'm gonna make my
calls by the [__] school right now
because that what else do we have guys
we you know
when the system fails us
what can we [__] do
19 cops waiting there for somebody to
tell them to go in
we're not even human anymore guys
we've become [__] computers like well
he said not there's kids in there
getting shot
now to those 19 cops not one of those
[__] had a child
to at least say to himself [__] hop in
these pants they tased the woman they
handcuffed another mom
this is crazy
she went back in and got her kids and
she went back in
guys what is it coming down to so this
is what i say to you if you're a parent
listen a couple weeks ago my uh
you know we get these games my daughter
watches gets these games so all her
friends sign up on these [__] games
before she downloads them my wife looks
back and forth she calls our friend sean
and
la who works on games and
we go over the game you know i don't
know anything about listen i don't even
download a [__] app okay i don't know
anything about this [__] okay when i
played when i was a kid i played life
i didn't play games i don't know how to
play chapters that's what you do on a
rainy day you know what i'm saying when
this sun out you attack the [__] sun
so i don't know anything about this but
these [__] kids today with their apps
and all this [__] so
they all download an app again you know
i talked to mercy about two weeks ago
mercy pulls me on the slide she goes dad
i went upstairs
and uh
and a guy had said something to me to
send me pictures or something like that
i don't [__] know i got mercy
you know what your mom told you i don't
want no [__] problems with these apps
if you think they're a little kinky do
not answer anybody do not
talk to them they're not going to
threaten your dad they don't even
[__] know my number
well what happened one of the mom's
[__] uh my her daughter forgot this
phone
and at the house
so she went in to get it and once she
went in
she was getting text messages from one
of the guys that to send the nude
pictures and [__] videotape and all
this [__] so she called all the [__]
moms
the moms and
i spoke to the woman a week later at the
field and i'm like what happened and she
was telling me what these people were
saying what the [__] is going on guys
what the [__] is going on
are they making these games so these
kids get i mean there's no [__]
protection for our kids no more
you have to look at their [__] ipads
and their [__] codes you have to
share them they cannot run a world
by themselves there's shitty people
there's a bunch of people walking around
like i was after my mother died right
now you know a bunch of people walking
around i don't blame them i don't blame
them for two years they've been told
they're gonna die
they're getting checks they need a
vaccine they gotta get a vaccine and
they'll lose your [__] job
what the [__] has happened here the last
three years so i can't imagine why i
tell you people i don't care how tough
somebody is i don't care they cut you
off keep driving
don't get into an argument nobody on the
street because
listen 20 years when i was growing up
things were bad now think about it the
last two years
we've been treated like [__] monkeys
like [__] monkeys the last two years
can you imagine working all [__] year
after the pandemic have you looked at a
plane ticket lately ladies and gentlemen
go look at the plane ticket go find your
favorite destination and go look at a
plane ticket lee had to cancel his plane
ticket to la's trip because they won a
thousand dollars for a [__] ticket to
la round trip in the back with [__]
victims yeah they want the hotel leaves
to stay at was 135 they want 290.
it's going to cost him 3 000 to go to
l.a for a rental car
guys what the [__] and the more we
support this [__] the the higher they're
gonna raise the [__] prices guys
i paid
980 for a ticket it was my favorite
ticket to the east coast
the club for you people don't know
they give you 7.50
so for a plane ticket
so for the difference of 150 or whatever
the [__] it is you could live like a
[__] doctor or you could sit in the
back like a [__] month they're giving
you 7.50
and you know and and i took it for years
it wasn't taking money out of my
family's pocket i wasn't being a [__]
tough guy i just liked sitting by myself
to have a little bed if i won a nod
and it was 8.90
and i'm [__] jet blue
you know what that ticket is now
so what's double double would be 1800
seventy percent
that plane ticket went up with the same
amenities and i gotta wear a mask or i
gotta sit next to somebody who's [__]
angry i'm not flying nowhere
i just i just got my jersey license and
i was supposed to get an id because
you're not supposed to fly in a year or
two without id
and my wife was like ragging on me about
the [__] idea and i go listen i told
you i'm not going nowhere i'm not
planning on taking any [__] trips not
at all this year
not at all not while things are like
this
why would i i could go down the [__]
shore and just sit on a [__] beach i
go long branch every [__] day i'm
gonna start doing that on wednesdays
you know carlos my buddy carlos looked
at this [__] house he's up north and
he's like i'm sick and tired of sitting
at home him and i like the same [__] i
go you know what from now on on
wednesday just pick me up
just pick me up we'll go somewhere i i
got to be back by three so it's perfect
it's one of those short days you know i
don't need to do much i don't need to be
a big shot
i'm in hawaii for what to pay 22 for
[__] water to get raped from a to z
not really wait until all this [__] goes
away
and then we'll move on but man
it's just been
a [__] [__] storm lately
and uh
i came down the other day and i didn't
really think about it i watched the
first
press conference like i don't like
listen i don't care less about amber and
johnny depp they don't put a dime in my
pocket i really don't give a [__] i
haven't watched a minute of that
i had people send me things do you think
she's snorting coke yeah she's throwing
coke in my [__] tissue leave me the
[__] alone you know i have 20 000 people
that besides that i don't give a [__] i
don't need to watch that [__]
you know yeah i get home and i'm
scrolling through the thing and i see a
cnn thing and i see all these [__] uh
old dinosaurs
old dinosaur politicians up there
with a bunch with 22
dummies behind them you know those dudes
that stand behind you why are you
standing there then they look at the
camera like to show their wives did you
see me i was standing behind j governor
judge abbott who gives a [__] i wouldn't
want to stand behind them in front of
them to the [__] side that guy's got
the stink of death on him 19 [__] 21
[__] bodies i don't want to be around
that [__] dead [__] and
that's a fact guys
somebody listen i've always told you
somebody's got an answer
i've been around for a long time and all
these little stupid debts somebody's
gotta ask and within four or five years
you see the cancer start coming you see
all the [__] bad luck because
somebody's gotta answer for these little
kids
19 kids that went to school they were
gonna graduate thursday
i mean what the [__] i got a third grade
i got a nine-year-old girl
the youngest person they shot was eight
and that shooter
why would you shoot him 18 times
i would have shot him in his [__]
legs i would have taken his [__] legs
out
now he's a [__] [__] in a texas
[__] prison
forget the [__] death penalty that's
off the table
that guy's got to live for 50 [__]
years i want that prison to get him the
best doctor in the world
because i want that [__] to live
though he's 80 years old i want him to
be in that type of shape because i know
for a fact he's gonna get raped and
[__] mangled every goddamn day of his
life
for what he did to those little kids who
never did a thing in their life never
did anything
the worst thing they did was maybe
[__] uh [__] their pants uh not put
their toys back in the garage that was
the only crime these kids [__] never
did so
this is really [__] taking me for a
loop and i'm sorry i gotta talk about
this on a monday but i want to open your
guys eyes that
guys hug your kids every day
kiss them every day tell them you
[__] love them every day it's gotten
back to this is it this is defcon 4.
level 4 this is it this is everybody
volume 4 level 4. this is it
this is it when you when cops are scared
to go in
to save children because they're
commanded not to
i don't know what to tell you guys
we've lost touch with humanity again i
want to repeat one of my guys on patreon
said to me that
nearly swept me off my feet everybody's
worried about the milk
shortage and the bottle and baby formula
shortage and the lumber shortage
nobody's worried about the love shortage
that's what worries me
it takes
everything out of everything i want to
do
because i got love for everything i do i
love you [__] i don't do i do
this because i love talking to you
[__] and talking [__] and
bringing you interesting people to
listen to their story to let you know
you're not [__] up
i do this podcast to let you know
there's nothing wrong with you because
if there's something wrong with you
there's something wrong with me and i
made it happen i made it work for me i
don't give a [__]
so there's nothing wrong with you but
now
while there's nothing wrong with you
there's nothing wrong with you
there's something wrong with the people
around you right now
the people around this [__] neatest
you know a kid shooting up a school a
kid shooting up a supermarket if that's
not a [__] yell for help
if that's not a [__] yell for help
shooting [__] a supermarket on a
saturday afternoon
you know
it's just something that you have to pay
attention to as an american right now
and go wow
we're living in different times i gotta
make different priorities and do uh
different [__] things you know
i'm trying to find a way to maybe donate
some money to the families i i mean i
wouldn't even know where to start when
you lost a child
what can i do to replace that child the
boat
[__] house what could replace that
child
nothing you could never
you could never fix
the pain in your heart when you have
something like that
especially knowing that you could have
saved that little child that didn't do
anything didn't do anything
you could have saved that little child i
feel bad for the [__] 19 cops or how
many cops that were out there
you know may god [__] bless their
souls when they're in [__] help
taking it up the ass by hitler for not
going in there
if i'm walking down the street and
there's a fire my 60 year old raggedy
ass
and somebody says to me there's a kid in
there i'm going in that house i don't
care about my life
i already did what i had to do i already
made enough mistakes for three lifetimes
you know so if you're one of those cops
stand you have a child
nothing
you gotta worry about that you know you
call your dentist you get a [__]
machine
you call your lawyer you got a machine
you call a [__] driver's license
bureau you get a [__] machine
what happened to humanity man what
happened to [__] humanity just
showing people
you're a little human from that's not
about the [__] rules
if it was about the rules for me i broke
them a long [__] time ago
this is when your inner inner voice
comes on you go this is what i need to
do
to do the right thing and guys i [__]
up enough of my life i don't have to
[__] brag to you guys about it
but i've always said how can i be a
better person the next day
how can i be better after this how can i
be the bigger [__] man how can i
you know how can i
get away from this to make my life that
much better and i've been doing this my
whole [__] life guys
i had a serious [__] problem i had a
couple [__] problems you know i'm
saying who the [__] my kid
i had a couple problems and i dealt with
them and
here we are today and i'm very proud
that i [__] dealt with them
but this [__] that's going on
i i don't even know where to start
is it going to change if i go on stage
and crack jokes
and take you away for 30 minutes or 45
minutes not really
it's just a [__] band-aid
this thing that we're going through as
americans right now
it's gonna take time
it's gonna [__] take time the world's
not healthy we got a war going on we're
putting sanctions on korea
you know and guys yeah
i'm from the old school that whatever's
gonna happen is gonna happen we still
gotta push forward and do what the [__]
we do right
but for the first time i even had a
break from that and go
what the [__] is really going on here
we could laugh we'd get high we could do
everything we can to forget about it
but it's right in front of us
so it starts with you as an american
don't start with me doesn't start with
mike
it stopped it starts with us
in the words of whatever you know it's
time to
clean up our backyards who says that
is it cypress hill or
jump up or something like that one of
those old rap song
it's time to look you know clean up your
own [__] backyard right now we've all
gone through a lot of [__] the last two
years all of us have
but now it's time to say what the [__]
is really going on
you know they opened up the country and
we [__] as americans ran out there
thinking that that was it the end of the
world
you know there's 92 [__] bands on
tour right now there's a thousand
productions there's a million comedians
on tour
and
you guys think you're going to take care
of your life by going to a show or going
to a broadway show or
to see some [__] comedian or go see
some [__] movie you think top gun is
going to change what's going on in the
[__] world today
what do you think what do you think
[__] he's going to get val kilmer
with his scarf around his neck and
they're going to go fight the villains
of the [__] world good luck my friend
it's time for us to [__] sit down and
go wow what are my capabilities and what
are my capabilities what could happen
you know it used to be 10 years ago
that'll never happen
in my school that will never happen in
my son's school that'll never happen at
my wife's work that'll never happen you
know guess what it's [__] happening
guys
it's happening and it's happening in
your own backyard i'm one of those
people who cares what happened in ohio
that'll never happen in jersey [__]
give it a give it a week or two
especially at this momentum give it a
[__] week or two
so it's really time to lift your head up
a little bit and go what the [__] is
going on
what can i do
what can i do as an american to make
my life better and mike's i'm not you
know you know you can't save the [__]
world guys
we're just trying to make each other
lives better the people we love the
people we care for
you know but like i said to you guys i
for years i always thought about
what the [__] happened in 95 when i went
off the [__] i mean guys i was doing
coke
two three days a week in those days but
seven days and five days in a row that
never was me i didn't care about comedy
i didn't take a shower i remember that i
ran out of coke and i used to have a
wall behind the shower i threw entry
packages i took the whole wall down
there must have been 300 packages in
there not one package had [__] in it i
mean
guys i could sit here for hours and tell
you these disgusting drug stories
because i went through
but for years i wondered why i did
things like that what would make a human
being
wanna [__]
had two streaks going down his nose my
my nose looked like the batmobile when
the fire came out like that for weeks i
had [__] two little scars from the
straw scraping up the skin
and from the shitty coke burning through
my [__] skin for years i thought
about what it was i never understood
that it was something to do with kids
when it comes to kids man i
am not good my anger goes up quickly
whether it's a [__] pedophile
whether it's somebody hitting your kid
and they're not supposed to
whether it's uh you know
going online and bothering the kid
all that [__] gets to me
and it gets to me for a couple reasons
it gets me because
the kids today
and i'm sick of talking about this and i
if you watch earthquake special on
showtime or on netflix you know our kids
today are not who we were not by a
[__] long shot and i i don't know
what to tell you
i don't know what happened
you know i i got into this in 92 i i
tried to become a human being in 95
and in [__] uh 2010 there's no kids
on the streets there's no
you know i don't know what the [__]
happened
but
these people attack these children
because they don't
our children today
as sad as the seems they got no [__]
common sense
look at these kids
they got no common sense
and us that parents are not doing
anything to help these [__] kids
oh he likes to play video games are you
[__] crazy
that's okay to play a video game a night
but not when you're a kid your whole
world is video games how's that child
gonna adjust socially to anything
i mean this is the [__] i think about i
look at my daughter you don't think i
worry i [__] worry man
i worry i i think about all this [__]
that went on with girls and the comedy
store and [__] you know all the lies
and everything
guys i'm trying to raise a door that
this will not happen to
this one these things will not happen to
her
you know what makes a a nice american
girl that comes from a nice family
moved to l.a and suck vikram's dick the
yoga guy with that little bikini on and
yes it was one of my jokes but it was
one of my jokes because it was
how my world collides with the rest of
the world
i don't know how a white girl
from ohio can move to la
and next thing you know she's blowing
some [__] dirty [__] i don't even
know what the [__] he is tunisian that
smells like curry and god knows what
else that that's a yoga teacher that's
got [__] hummus coming out of his
ball sack
what would make a woman do that to get
ahead what would what do you
do by getting ahead by blowing some yoga
guy you know how many [__] guys are
walking around l.a telling young girls
they're producers
meanwhile they're [__] guys with
accents who drench themselves like
cologne you ever smell those guys that
don't even shower they just pick a
little
cologne over sweat and it's got that
[__]
hummus odor to you and these girls are
telling i'm a producer what would do
what film have you worked on oh
i don't know and they're gonna sleep
with these guys so when i saw all that
[__] going on
i'm like you know what i gotta i gotta
raise my daughter the right [__] way
because these women out of their [__]
minds every day i open a [__] twitter
you go on twitter there's a check on my
twitter that's [__] sucking every day
on twitter
i mean [__] and suck it on twitter i
got like two of those i don't follow
them i don't know these people are they
just [__] show up on my twitter
[__] i got some chick that is the
ugliest woman in north america
like you could tell this girl got hit
with all types of [__] and she's like a
patreon chick that shows a [__] and
stuff like that she calls herself some
who [__] raised you
who [__] raised you so this is my
concern this has been my concern since i
left los angeles this has been my
concern
you know that just
the kid thing is all out now so now i
got to take my [__] daughter i
already had a long talk with my wife
i'm going to be talking to a lot things
are going to change in this [__]
house
and that's it man because i can't deal
with this [__] no more i really can't
you know i've had some struggles lately
i was telling mike when he came in
i've been struggling a lot lately with
the [__] podcast whether or not to do
a podcast if you don't have a zoom to
move the office my wife my [__] house
i'm bored to death should i do stand-up
should i not do [__] stand-up guys i
don't want to do anything
i don't want to do anything
i just want to rest
smoke [__] pot and sell some [__]
good weed to you [__] that's
all i want to do i don't do anything i
did i did everything i had to do my
[__] soul is filled with [__]
i'm just
i just want to have a good time
raise my [__] daughter i don't want
to stay out late i don't want to go to
studio 54 i don't want to do nothing i
don't want to do coke i don't want to do
nothing i don't want to see nobody i
want to go see jelly roll i'm going to
go see [__] allison chains and bush
at the
pnc whatever
you know i'm keeping it [__] local
this summer and i'm minding my p's and
q's i'm doing this for joe next weekend
i don't know what's gonna happen after
that i have no [__] idea all i know
is that i'm gonna try my hardest friday
and saturday i'm gonna
you know just be me that's it i'm not
worried about it at all anymore i can't
there's so many other things i need to
worry about my life right now that are
[__] just
and like i said i never cared about
nothing outside i lived my life guys
being
the [__] pro
like i don't give a [__] what's going on
in the world i gotta get up every
morning i preach this for years you guys
have heard me
you guys have heard me talk about it i
don't give a [__] guess what
guys for the first time in a long time i
gotta give a [__] now
i gotta give a [__] now because like i
said for years we're like that that'll
never happen to us
i don't think the people
in our rule d whatever [__] part of
texas thought i don't think the people
in buffalo ever thought that
you know so do me a favor please keep
your [__] eyes open you know
hug your kids
kiss them before they go to school when
they come back
because we're living in a new [__]
world with a new [__] set of rules
and that's why you could do is uh smoke
pot in your house you gotta [__] be
attentive
when you're outside you know my neighbor
told me she was walking to work the
other day
you know 10 feet from her homeless guy
stabbed a guy on 42nd street
she got sure i didn't even hear it go
down all i heard was a yelling people
screaming
[__] 9 15 in the morning
what possesses some guy what possesses
some stinky [__] bum that's sleeping
on a box
to get up and just stab a [__] guy on
uh
times square i don't know
i don't [__] know anymore guys but
this is the world as we see it
like i said it's memorial day i didn't
want to come on here on a [__] monday
and and talk this nonsense but sometimes
guys
we just gotta have somebody open our
eyes to what's going on sometimes we
don't pay attention i'm one of those
guys i always appreciate
when somebody makes me aware of
something we got monkey pucks
how the [__] did this start can somebody
tell me
how to [__] monk they got 10 people with
monkey pox
some guy went to france and [__] some
got no i'm not i'm not doing this
you guys got me with the bat in [__]
china that spread [__] coven then
they come from a bat in a laboratory now
it's a [__] monkey pox when does it
end
when does it [__] end
we're getting it from all over
every [__] day
i mean
thank god
yahoo is a [__] thing i gotta click
and most of the time i don't click onto
it i even get my sports from espn sports
now because i'm so sick of clicking on
[__] yahoo
it's uh it's absurd the [__] how can
the [__] if somebody said it the other
day how can the chris rock smack
be so relevant
and the buffalo shooting is gone now
like that's what we focus on like we're
still talking about a stupid [__]
actor smacking a dummy [__] comic
at a great [__] event and we're still
[__] stuck on that that's how you
know we're still stuck on man amber
heard dawg it's over like i told you by
watching this i hope you learned that
what uncle joey was telling you i was
cutting through the lines what's that
expression when you read between the
lines i'm going to tell you right now
what that whole amber heard johnny depp
thing is about
hollywood people
you people are watching that you can't
doug i'm 50 years old i never dreamed of
[__] [__] on somebody's bed i'll
[__] in my [__] toilet i'll [__] in a
box and put in your drawer i've never
dreamed of [__] the bed i don't know
about you that girl is white she looks
like she's educated she looks like a
family has money that's the [__] that
goes out to l.a to sell their soul
those are the girls that come back to
you in 10 years and go kristen off made
me suck this dick well look at you
look at you you're all over it you're
all [__] over it now you when you
look at that amber heard and johnny depp
look at both of them go they're both
two disgusting
hollywood people don't even listen to
that stuff
it's disgusting
i was at dinner a couple nights ago with
like three friends and they were telling
me what and i'm like guys
now you know why i left that way
listen to that [__] listen to that
gibberish
listen to who that her friends are who's
her friends the rapist and [__] elon
musk
uh whatever his name is uh
orange pineapple pineapple yeah
pineapple express
that's who they hang out with they got
no normal people in their lives so they
bring more [__] creepy hollywood
people in their lives
and johnny depp i don't know i don't
know every time i see the singer from
aerosmith i think somebody robbed him
that's it did you watch steven tyler on
[__] rogue and watch steven tyler on
rogan watch him talk and then look at
[__] uh at this [__] wannabe
[__] guitar player you know you don't
see me [__] with bracelets and and a
chain and yeah then he [__] almost
killed joe perry in long island he gave
him some [__] pill that his heart
stopped beating and [__] in 10
[__] minutes that's the guy you had
yeah any death hat
that's what hollywood is get a real
[__] look at it
that's why guys like me would never ever
make it in hollywood i don't know about
that [__]
dating somebody just to get ahead that
if you can't tell that what that was
let them there was no love there
and he don't give a [__] either because
he gets his dicks up 18 times a day this
is something he found the stupid chick
that wanted to move in with him here's
another [__] dummy that wants to move
in with me that's all that is that's all
guys this is all this is
why do you guys even watch this [__]
support this [__] is what i've been
telling you about years those people
are [__] disgusting
they got no souls they don't like that
shooting should have happened in l.a
because those people don't care about
their kids they just have kids to tell
people my kids don't have kids you go to
a pool they go there with that mexican
nanny you go to a restaurant they're
with that mexican nanny those people
don't care about anybody they just talk
and you fall for it oh he's so sweet no
they're not
that garbage they will sell their mother
for [__] a movie they'll sell their
mother it's like my man [__] by the
way he's got some [__] last week for
being too real ricky gervais
you know nobody likes the truth anymore
guys we're living in a society
that god forbid you tell the truth oh
god forbid you tell the truth about
anything today you're [__] ostracized
you know bill maher did you see bill
maher last week what he had to say
that he was trendy being [__] uh you
know
it was just trendy which it really is
you don't even know why you're doing it
i told you guys 20 years ago i was at
the gaucho grill across the street from
the lab factory
and there was a gentleman in the table
behind me
and he was so gay i had nothing against
him but in the back of my mind i go
nobody could be that guy
nobody
they're so confused when they move out
there they become gay look at the chick
from donny brasco
the chick that used to be a lesbian
whatever now she's married with two
[__] kids
they will say or do anything
to get ahead
when then trust me when they go to l.a
bro listen you see it it doesn't take a
genius to see people who have turned gay
just have something to do
just to talk to people just to get
invited to parties
that's how far you know what goes to la
all the broken people
from the all the good states that's what
heads out in l.a
and once you get they they brainwashed
like 90 percent of them do and 10 of
them don't i saw them for what the [__]
they were they're nasty [__] people
that think that somebody's got to say
something to them let me tell you
something i fell on that spell at one
time when i was weak because of the coke
i didn't want to lose the coke out of my
life once i got rid of the coke i had
nothing holding me down i told you
exactly what i was on my [__] mind on
all those sets oh my god this lady wants
me to do one of her freaking commercials
she's one of those people that always
wears a hat which i can't stand you know
those [__] huh you know like when you
see a guy with a hat his girlfriend told
him he looked cute in that hat and that
dumb [__] actually listened to
instead of saying shut the [__] up only
sinatra could wear this [__] hat but
all these damn these people wear hats to
everything every time i look at their
instagram that night she asked me can i
[__] can you shoot this to me i go on
one condition
that there ain't nobody there with a
[__] hat on
i don't want to see a hat she was like
what are you saying and i'm bringing my
own director
because i see the okie doke directors
you hang out with with the tattoo rolled
up t-shirt with a pigeon on their arm i
don't want that i got bonnie mcfarlane
she could direct [__] better than
half you [__]
and that's the way life is guys hey it's
memorial day [__] i just can't
we weren't even gonna do a podcast but i
go with everything that's going on in
the [__] world
let's talk to these beautiful people on
a monday morning god knows
if they had a [__] horrible weekend
like i did i didn't have a horrible
weekend but like i told you guys this
[__] just uh
it just uh didn't settle with me like
most things do
but anyway with that in mind uh we'll be
back wednesday
it might be a zoom it might be a [__]
guest
it might be being by myself i'm not sure
yet i don't know but whatever i [__]
do i'm gonna do the best job i can if
you don't like the zoom then don't watch
it
if you don't like the live gas then
don't watch if you don't like me by
myself then don't watch i know what to
tell you guys the end is near
that's it you follow me the end is
[__] near
so i want you guys to
think about what i talked about today
see what you could do as an american
to be a better [__] american to make
the people around you
grow a little bit
and just pray
pray that no this [__] happens to our
families
that we could uh raise our families not
any other [__] and that
it gets better for us
that's all i could say you know keep
writing keep writing your [__] goals
and we keep worrying about us we can't
control what happens outside but
we keep an eye on them that's the best
we could [__] do i can't tell you
what to do all i could tell you is keep
your eyes open
do the best you can don't go anywhere
you don't belong to be and don't believe
the [__] hype uh we are
in a short supply of love right now but
you know i love you [__] i'm
always here
i show up tip top magu whether i'm
[__] up what i'm doing all right and
i'm doing all right thanks to you
[__] have a great memorial day
with your families
eat smoke eat some ass do whatever the
[__] makes you happy it's your [__]
world as long as you do it in your
backyard and you don't get [__] shot
or whatever the [__] by these crazy
people or jesse smilet and now for a
word for my [__] sponsor jack
first of all i want to wish you a happy
memorial day number two
thank you for watching to join today and
also thank you for supporting me i'm
sorry
that it wasn't an upbeat [__] uh
joint today but
this type of situation takes me the [__]
down i'm sorry i brought it into your
life but anyway the joint is brought to
you by blue chew
if you're ready to sling dick blue chew
gotcha summer's here and it's time to
set off bottle rockets plus the bottle
rocket between your [__] legs blue
chew is tremendous you can take it
anytime anywhere
i don't want you to show up with dead
dick i want you to show up with heart
and a smile on your face
because that smile is [__]
contagious when your dick is hard am i
lying and the process is simple sign up
at bluetooth.com
talk to one of their medical license
providers once you're approved
you'll receive your prescription within
days
it's all online no doctor's office no
pharmacy no judgment it ships right to
your door in a discreet package
bluetooth tablets are made in the us a
[__] a
the strongest [__] country in the
goddamn world so if you could benefit
from extra confidence when it's time to
slick dick
blue chew can help and they got a
special deal
for the joint listeners you ready try
blue chew for free
when you use promo code joey at checkout
just pay five dollars for shipping
that's bluetooth.com
promo code joey to receive your first
month free that's bluechew.com for more
details
thanks to bluechu for sponsoring the
joint i want to thank annik a [__]
tremendous supplement company i [__]
love them this new black label alpha
brain is tremendous they even got the
packages that you could rip open lemon
lime fruit and it's like [__] like
the way i do with liquid iv only with
hydration from [__] on it the best
so do yourself a favor right now whether
you need the new mood the shroom tech
smart or the instrument tech immune we
got [__] on it so right now go to
honda.com
look at the [__] kettlebells club
mace i can't give you a discount on them
but i got you with 10 off on the
supplements on your first order press in
joey joint or church and get 10 percent
off from on it i want to thank honey and
i want to thank [__] blue chew
have a great week and i'll see you
[__] wednesday
tip
top magoo
[Music]
foreign
you